hello welcome to the debate on sky news
i'm martin stanford
here's our take on developments brought
together from america the uk and around
the world manhunt three weeks on the run
for the audacious convicts but how
and why
tragedy in tunisia bankruptcy in greece
are you postponing european travel
and celebrating july the 4th is that why
you're finding it hard to breathe after
the fireworks
it was an audacious prison escape months
of preparation dry runs and coercion of
prison staff
after three weeks on the run it's over
one escapee dead the other captured and
more than a dozen prison staff on
enforced leave this is the story of matt
and swett two of america's most wanted
and how they almost got away
but how did it happen well as usual
democrat commentator jeffrey robinson is
standing by in new york and conservative
commentator armstrong williams is in
washington armstrong these two guys very
nearly got over the border into canada
didn't they
you know believe it or not there's a
very popular national show in the united
states called i almost got away with it
and it's about people like them and i'm
sure they're ending up on the program
you know what it's it's not a perfect
storm but it's a plan that worked for a
while you know a one out of a thousand
sometimes it works where they have the
right plan the right accomplice uh and
they get away they find the right
territory to escape to that terrain in
new york is very difficult they found
the right trailer to hide themselves and
they found the pepper that they could
disguise the scent that would confuse
the dogs anybody who's a hunter like
myself understand that but you know it
was just a matter of time before law
enforcement caught up with them and took
them out and finally arrested them
jeffrey do we criticize the prison staff
for letting it happen at all
well i think there's a lot of people who
need to be questioned about this uh and
i disagree with you in that they almost
got away with it i think that that
armstrong's got it right they didn't
almost get away with it they uh they
were always gonna be caught first of all
the original plan was to go to mexico
and the way they had rehearsed it which
they did the night before they actually
escaped the night before and came back
into the prison is they ended up at the
wrong manhole and decided to change the
plan so they got that far they
understood how to do that they did not
understand how to survive in the woods
and and how to get where they were going
they only got 30 miles from dannemora
what's more the canadian border was
manned by both american law enforcement
and canadian law enforcement they
weren't going to get there and if they
had they would have been arrested there
so no no they were always doomed but the
point is about this it brings up what
a real story about american prisons
donna mora uh which is where clinton is
is 170 year old prisoner built in 1844
john tyler was president of the united
states when this was built and most
people never heard him it is a hell hole
the most famous prisoner ever held there
was lucky luciano
it's a terrible awful place to be and
you can understand why prisoners want to
escape what you most people don't
understand is that it's just as bad for
the prison staff and the guards to work
there as it is for them to be housed
there
well let's cross to washington and get
an insight from rod wheeler who's a
former homicide detective in dc they had
to had accomplices didn't they to do
this and we still don't know the full
range of exactly how many and what their
involvement was but the very fact they
could start those relationships in jail
and persuade someone to help them that's
worrying isn't it rod
well absolutely but i can tell you that
here in the united states it's not
unusual for prisoners to try to become
very close and very friendly with a lot
of the correctional officers as a matter
of fact right here in baltimore maryland
just last year 14 correctional officers
were arrested because they did have
involvement with prisoners personal
involvement with prisoners now what's
really fascinating about this case
though i must say is that not only the
escape itself which was very
sophisticated and very meticulous by the
way but how long these two individuals
were able to evade police which i can
tell you there was well over 1500
officers on the ground there in new york
state and we still could not find these
guys for a period of 23 days
and does that reflect badly on the
police themselves do you think their
techniques their approach their
intelligence was it all wrong
no i think there was a combination of
reasons as to why we could not find them
first of all we had well over 1800 maybe
even a thousand and so what happened was
we were we had to kind of separate and
spread our resources to try to follow up
on all of these leads i think the second
reason and armstrong touched on it is
that that area up there in new york let
me tell you that terrain is very very
difficult and even for the dogs we had
canine dogs sniffer dogs in that area
they picked up the scent they lost the
scent so and then it was raining it was
raining very very bad in that area so
all of those things combined these
individuals in their escape and kept
them out as long as they were armstrong
just reflect on geoffrey's thought about
the quality of life for the prison staff
are they paid enough for what they do is
is the working environment correct for
the job they have to take on
i don't think it's the pay
that we should concern ourselves with so
much uh there's a reason why we have the
prisoners and there's a reason why we
have those guards selected to
um to be on duty to make sure
that they um don't try to dastardly
escape that they tried recently but i
think what we forget about is the human
part i mean here is a woman who was
married she was able to be manipulated
by a prison guard it happens all the
time she was being able to be
manipulated by this prisoner she found
herself weak and once they are able to
con you into the point where you become
intimate with them and you become an
adulterer you're betraying your husband
you're betraying your oath of duty then
they have something to hold over your
head then it's very difficult for you
not to pursue what their agenda is and
what they don't understand that these
prisoners while they may think they
develop close relationships they care
nothing about these prison guards in
fact all they want are their cigarettes
other things they won't smuggle in or
find them try to find a way to escape
and they cannot do it with unless they
go through manipulating human emotions
manipulating their mind and eventually
having these sexual relationships and
that is the most powerful drug and what
people are willing to do to maintain
that to protect it to make sure they
don't lose their jobs which they did in
the end is just amazing these are the
kinds of things that you cannot factor
in and until you can separate and try to
deal with that issue of these
relationships going on you will see this
happening again jeffrey we have to
therefore ask the the governor don't we
about the staff
about the supervision of the staff the
support the staff get um in order that
these inappropriate relationships don't
flourish
well the superintendent of donna moore
and his deputy have both been put on
administrative leave but the problem is
much deeper than that and i i don't know
if armstrong has ever visited people in
prison i know rod certainly has uh and
i've interviewed people in prison and it
is a dismal unhappy place for everybody
and what struck me the first time i ever
went into a prison to interview somebody
was the amount of contraband that i saw
being brought in i mean it was
astonishing that things were being
brought into these prisoners who have
economic means and muscle to to get
certain things done and in many ways
control the atmosphere themselves uh you
see it on on on all the prison shows for
example that we have here uh where
certain gangs control certain parts of
the prison and the staff just can't
control that what we need to do now
after dinner more is to take a look at
who we incarcerate how we incarcerate
them and the conditions under which
these people are spending time
and what we can do to control them they
should not be running the uh the insane
asylum it's really up to us by the way
we also have private prisons in this
country and i know an awful lot of law
enforcement people are very down on the
whole idea of private prisons run for
profit it's time we took a big look at
who we incarcerate and how we hold them
but rob wheeler the problem with that i
guess is that um who cares really i mean
it's one of those problems in life but
for most ordinary citizens they pay
their taxes you get rid of the bad guys
throw away the key and forget about them
don't you well yeah that's the uh the
idea behind it but at the same time you
know the theory behind prison is
rehabilitation so that we can
rehabilitate and get these criminals
back to you know normal life in the
united states and obviously that's not
happening because obviously there
someone has dropped the ball with our
prison system and our penal institutions
whereby like i said earlier we see this
happening more often than not it's just
not as reported it's not as a big
deal as it was with these two guys matt
and sweat but i must say after working
many many years in law enforcement and
working and putting a lot of those
prisoners behind bars when these guys
get out they're very well schooled in
terms of how to break out and other
things like that that they learn inside
the institution so i think as a nation
we have to do our due diligence and
really take a look at our penal
institutions and ask
ourselves is this right for the way we
are now is this right for the time that
we're living in i'm strong there's no
appetite for that though is there really
there's no no politicians going to get
votes in this election year by saying we
need to be nicer to prisoners
oh absolutely not and
you know especially when you consider
some of the crimes that have been
committed you know but i do think there
should be focus on how these prison
guards are selected how easily
manipulated they are and i i think
jeffrey makes an excellent point there
are very dismal conditions there's a
lack of self-worth and self-esteem the
guards don't want to be in there um
these prisoners do every now and then
accumulate money that they're willing to
spare to get certain contrabands and
other illegal things in there and unless
you find people who have the character
who have everything to gain and they
cannot be bought and sold inside that
prison and they do their jobs and they
cannot be manipulated i think it
reflects more of the kind of people that
we put in each prison as prisoner guard
and why they are easily corrupted i
think that's where you need to revisit
because you get that in check then you
won't have the corporation in the fine
line between the prisoners and those
that are uh
employed to guard them and make sure
they don't have these kind of escapes
that we saw from these two who are
eventually one call and one was
eventually made his demise yeah but if
you're trying to give jeffrey somebody a
job whereby they're saying you're trying
to help somebody start a new life that's
one thing if you're just saying actually
your job is to keep that guy locked up
most of the day feeding minimal amount
of food in pretty hideous circumstances
and that's all your job entails that's
something completely different isn't it
yes it is and there's very little
rehabilitation that actually happens in
prison most of it is uh university-level
courses in crime for other prisoners by
the way they also have a number of a
real influence many of them have real
influence outside the prison gates you
get the gang bangers inside prison who
have their mates outside who can
intimidate guards families from the
outside it's a terrible situation but
let me say this you ask who cares i'll
tell you who cared about this one all of
those people the innocent people living
in clinton county new york who lived in
fear for three weeks the two hardcore
murderers were on the loose that's who
cares no no we pay our taxes to make
sure these people are kept inside and
have every right in the world to say
it's time to reorganize prisons to make
sure they stay inside you know um jerry
jeffrey makes another good point and
i'll tell you why uh part of the
survivor of these two escapees is that
they were able to find cabins and break
in and when the homeowners returned they
found things that were missing and was
out of order and they called law
enforcement and lo and behold they had
been in those places and you can imagine
if they walked in on some of these
innocent people in that cabin god knows
what would have happened so i do think
that the lives in that county were very
much threatened uh also in that process
jeffrey armstrong thanks for the moment
a reminder you can catch up with the sky
news debate on apple tv ruku and catch
up and of course at skynews.com
us
we're in july it's july the fourth
weekend and the summer holidays are
within touching distance but have recent
events forced a change of plan
do you ignore or embrace the threat of
terror attacks and bankrupt countries
just have a look at this map for
instance this is the terror alert
available around europe and the
mediterranean the country's alarming
number of them in bright red then you've
got your ambers and your yellow and only
little old switzerland there look in
green
he's actually got a low terror threat
does that not just fill you with dread
where in the world is left
cuba perhaps well paul rudin is the
executive vice president of the american
society of travel agents the world's
largest association of travel
professionals paul rudin have you seen a
change of plan for many people this
summer
no martin we excuse me we really haven't
the data for this year is very strong
fares
generally are down to europe in the
middle east
they're up in a few select places but
mostly down
and the volume of traffic continues to
rise at a
not great rate but it is going up so the
available data is is a couple of months
old but
you have to understand that most of the
business
for
trips to europe and the middle east was
sold
uh
in the spring of this year and even in
the winter of last year that is the
normal cycle for selling the north
atlantic
so we're anticipating a pretty good year
i think if we were seeing massive
cancellations we would have heard about
them and we haven't
so despite the problem that greece might
not have a currency or any kind of
economy left
um and other mediterranean countries may
well suffer as well despite the fact
there
are terrorists running a mark on
tunisian beaches you think american
travelers have built a stern and stuff
are they and they'll stick to their
plans
well either they will continue to go to
the places they originally intended to
go some of them will
will change their plans and go to other
places if they can find hotel rooms and
air transportation to get them there
but again the data does not suggest that
there's a massive reaction to this
tragically our entire world is afflicted
with these terrorist attacks they're
unpredictable
no one including the most expert people
can say where the next attack's going to
come from and i think most americans
have decided they're not going to be
intimidated about that that doesn't mean
they're going to go into egypt uh in in
you know when their riots going on in
the center of cairo
have to make their own choices about
these things and most people are pretty
intelligent about that and they talk to
their professional travel agent and get
good advice about where they should go
and where they shouldn't go
let's bring in jeffrey robinson in new
york and armstrong williams uh who's
standing by in washington uh jeffrey
would i don't know if you were planning
to come to europe this summer or into
the fall but would you change your plans
in the light of what's going on
not at all and i don't think i don't
think most americans i think paul is
absolutely right perhaps if you were
planning on vacationing this summer in
tripoli or damascus or benghazi you may
have second thoughts but if you're going
to paris london or rome no i mean it's
these are these are major vacation
tourist centers and people are
relatively safe now the even the french
are going to still go to the riviera in
the month of august and i suspect that
the englishmen who like mad dogs go out
in the noonday sun have no plans at all
to change their plans to come to orlando
and disney i i'm sure that the summer
vacation will go off just as planned for
most people despite the problems and by
the way greece does have a currency it's
called the euro and right now hotel
rooms and restaurants are pretty cheap
all right so um armstrong jeffrey seems
to be suggesting that you might want to
take out snap up a bargain and get over
to greece deliberately perhaps
you know i i actually think have a very
unique perspective
on this topic for the last 26 years
my business partners and i have owned
boutique hotels in the south of france
and in spain
and so for the last 26 years without
interruption i've either traveled to
europe or to the middle east for at
least a month or more and already on my
schedule i will be in one of those um
targeted areas
in spain
and you know we've gone to israel at the
height of the terrorist attacks on
restaurants and cafes we had been on the
street when buses were exploded
and we heard cell phones going off and
realizing that nobody was going to
answer because their loved one was dead
so we've been in the heart of it and the
last thing you should do is give in to
terrorists and given to terrorist
threats because they win and if you use
common sense not get into taxis or cars
or go to places that you're unfamiliar
with if you follow common sense you stay
close to the premises of your hotel uh i
think you're pretty safe yes people are
targeted but i think you you have to
really go off the beaten path in a very
independent way to be a victim of an
attack especially if we spent a month in
egypt and they told us there are certain
cars you don't get into there are
certain routes you don't travel if you
follow the guys of that country and you
don't try to think that you're
invincible i think the likelihood of you
being a victim of a terrorist attack is
highly unlikely paul rudin do you think
that some of the determination that
armstrong talks of let's go ahead with
the vacation we have planned let's not
change our things because otherwise the
terrorists win is that a sentiment do
you think at the heart of most americans
who are traveling this summer
without a doubt and and i and i think
it's been that way
this this problem of terrorism began
and i don't think it will ever let up uh
he's absolutely correct you you simply
cannot crawl into your shell and and
stay home
um
and americans are not going to do that
they will consult their professional
travel agents about where they can go
and and where they should perhaps
shouldn't go we give advice all the time
about avoiding uh big crowds where where
you know there's demonstrations going on
and so forth people should stay away
from those things but if you use common
sense and and pay attention to the news
about what's going on around you even
when you're in that country uh
the chances of something happening to
you are probably a lot less than they
are
uh that you might be involved in a
serious accident headed to the airport
so or even going to work uh in the major
city in the united states so i i think
americans will will stay the court
generally support that jeffrey and
armstrong you're men of the world well
traveled i know let's let's ask you some
top tips i mean jeffrey in terms of
europe uh it's not just the obvious the
france the spain's or greece for
instance i mean
what the dalmatian coast little old
croatia that's quite nice i hear
yes it is i've actually i sailed there
many years ago i listen i lived for many
years in the south of france and i would
love to know the addresses of those
boutique hotels that armstrong lives and
so that my wife and i can be his guest
in them we spent a lot of time
my kids were born there and she's from
there so the south of france is still
one of the great places but you know
portugal is still one of the one of the
great secrets of europe uh because they
put it way off to the side uh most
tourists
american tourists don't get there the
british discovered it years ago because
it was pretty cheap and cheerful and and
good food and great beaches there's a
lot of europe to be enjoyed and there
are small towns in france where you can
still find the restaurant owned by mama
and papa where they grow the vegetables
in the garden there's a lot to be said
for france for italy for england england
is filled with surprises and again
as paul said if you consult your travel
agent a professional travel agent we'll
help guide you
and tell you pretty much where things
are safe you're going to have a great
time and armstrong is there anywhere in
europe where you don't have a hotel
of course but i've got to tell you there
are some gyms
in europe i mean prague
um you go down to the mafia coast in
italy
uh
just incredible places especially if you
go to churches with all the skulls of
the victims from hitler's reign to see
that history
and also
in greece to go down to the wine country
in the country where they have the
farming country it's just breathtaking
it reminds you of what their natural
wonders are which is quite different
from the united states and i got to tell
you i spent a lot of time in rotted dam
in amsterdam there's more than just the
red light district to see in those
spectacular places so yes europe is just
absolutely wonderful to visit especially
during the summer but especially during
the fall when it's much cooler and the
prices are far better when you go in the
fall than doing the dead of summer where
the prices are sky high paul can i just
ask you a bit of close a bit closer to
american mainland and that is cuba now
relations are supposed to be thawing
there are people rushing to go visit
it's not quite a land rush just yet
because the uh the u.s government
still has in place a travel ban with
respect to u.s citizens
and only select categories of people can
go there they cannot go there for
tourism purposes
we're working very hard to get the
congress to see the light on this
uh we're part of a major coalition on
the on the subject that is active right
now uh putting huge resources into this
so we can open up cuba to travel by
americans as it should be the policy we
have in place now
simply hasn't accomplished its purpose
in its time for change when that change
happens we expect major major uh volumes
of people going to cuba by air and on
cruise ships
and paul
just tell us you said some people are
allowed to go is it very
few what category of person do you have
to be then to be allowed to go to cuba
right now
well there there are certain kinds of
people to people
interactions that are permitted
education
programs that are permitted
but they're very tightly controlled and
and very limited as to who can qualify
so
the good news is that one of the major
global distribution systems has just
opened up its systems
uh
to the possibility of booking air trips
there for those people who are qualified
to go now and we're we're hopeful we can
get those those categories expanded uh
to the point where there are no
categories and
it's the only country in the world i
believe that we have this kind of
restriction for americans should be able
to go wherever they want to go wherever
their good judgment tells them that they
would like to go and experience the
culture and that's the goal
we have for cuba
paul rudin thank you very much indeed
finally this weekend couldn't have come
at a better time for july the 4th
celebrations but
and there is always a but nowadays a
study has found that the firework
displays boosted the levels of airborne
microscopic particles and these can
cause serious respiratory and
cardiovascular problems let's ask
jeffrey robinson in new york and
armstrong williams in washington d.c
about this jeffrey are these guys going
to find something to moan about now
well well now just hold on i'm going to
invite my friend armstrong to gang up
with me against you guys in britain
there may very well be problems with the
fireworks but you're talking about the
fourth of july and i might remind you
guys in britain that the 4th of july was
not as you consider it the illegal
overthrow of the rightful british
government by force and violence that's
not the way we see it and i understand
you may not celebrate it but here's the
deal if armstrong will join me we would
like to invite you even with our smelly
polluting fireworks to our barbecues
because there are no grudges 239 years
later
to celebrate the fourth of july with us
we don't hold a grudge and we're not
going to dump your tea in the harbor
anymore happy fourth of july despite the
fireworks
thank you jeffrey armstrong
listen
what you're speaking about will be the
last thing on america's mind it's a
holiday there's alcohol there's
cigarettes there's there's love and
warmth and we have a lot to celebrate
especially after what happened in
charleston and how we saw americans come
together there's still pride and hope
for america that is still that shining
city on the hill and let me tell you uh
we all realize we're going to die of
something i think many americans say
we're going to get a little something in
our lungs that's the day that's
worthwhile to get it yeah and if the
guys try and take the fireworks out of
the july the 4th does that take a lot
away from it
they're not going to take the fireworks
out of july 4th that is a that is a
hopeless dream to say the least you want
to galvanize all americans that's the
way to do it
armstrong
i'm sure you've noticed that have you
noticed that our british friends didn't
bring this story up on guy fox night
now they are our british friends and
they will celebrate with us
indeed we will and we have really smelly
bonfires that night as well which goes
to add even more pollutants into the
atmosphere i'm sure
gentlemen thank you both very much
indeed
happy for the joy that's it for this
edition of the debate you can continue
watching sky news on apple tv on roku on
catch up and of course at skynews.com
until next time goodbye